I'm going to end with one beef question
for you because there is no doubt in my
mind that a certain kill scene that
you're involved in is going to wind up
being one of the best screen deaths of
all of all time this year so when you're
filming a moment like that specifically
when she's pressing the button do you
think Naomi is doing that with the
intention to kill with self-preservation
being the top priority or a mix of both
I I think that for me it's always I I
try so hard not to judge the characters
that I'm playing and really put myself
in that situation I am most easily
scared person if I was in that situation
I would have fainted probably before I
could even run there
um for me it's I think there's such a
conflict in that moment of like I want
to help but like what am I doing like
like I think there's would you know when
you've been I've been in life in deaf
situations when you're in those
situations you're not like thinking in a
precise or concise way
um at least she was not so I don't think
there's any intention but to like maybe
help Maybe not maybe just do what the
director says and the writer says and
Sonny says so
um I think that that's exactly what
happens and which is why there's
probably so much conflict in her by the
end of it of like what just happened oh
my God you know that moment effed me up
I literally sent Ashley a reaction video
my hand over my mouth I was shocked and
you were watching and you said we're on
this
um we're on this episode and I was like
you were on this episode I was like what
what were you a background what are you
talking about yeah yeah uh but I mean I
could unpack that episode for hours
briefly what's your take is because
Naomi just said uh to Jordan oh oh you
want to leave me for her I don't think
she did on purpose I think when
someone's running towards you screaming
do not close it then you're like okay
I'm waiting for you I'm waiting I just
think she does not have periphery
watches
no she's never pressed that right you're
right you don't know if it's a sensitive
but
we try